derniers préparatifs hier matin avant de
passer près d'un mois et demi sur la
route comme leurs aînés de la marche
pour la liberté contre la discrimination
en octobre 1983
vous aviez martin se sont lancé le défi
de rallier paris à pied depuis marseille
tous les deux gilet jaune
les deux hommes espèrent alerté le
gouvernement sur la situation dans les
quartiers le chômage la précarité ou
encore la discrimination
franck est déjà présent en 1983 espère
être reçue à l'elysée
notre but à nous c'est de fait n'a pas
de quoi lancer un appel commun son
gouvernement aux députés
il ya tous ces politiciens qu'ils
reçoivent les marchands pas ce que c'est
on est des personnes en vie dans les
quartiers toute la nuit
depuis 40 ans ni dans les quartiers et
on a besoin de se faire entendre alors
cenap et de kaunas ça serait bien qu'on
nous reçoivent nous reçoivent à l'elysée
pour qu'on puisse se remettre nos
doléances que monsieur marc randall est
prévu il ya deux ans de ça dany merhy
qu'en définitive nos doléances à la
mairie on les a remis en définitive ils
ont évoqué on sait pas où ils ont
embouti une marge de près de 800
kilomètres jusqu'à la capitale
mais avant d'arriver à paris elle est de
gilet jaune ont programmé plusieurs
étapes
il espère ainsi récupérer en route les
nombreux cahiers de doléances rédigé
lors du grand débat national organisé
par emmanuel macron en janvier 2019
question logement elle les deux
marcheurs compte sur la générosité des
français sur la logistique hébergement
nous comptons sur les gens déjà
actuellement nous avons eu des dons
financiers qui nous permettront de nous
entretenir et peut-être des fois même
prendre une sorte d'hôtel si on commence
à faire plusieurs jours en mode camping
et ensuite nous cherchons un petit peu
la charité par exemple notre premier
arrêt à salon de provence
nous sommes humblement hébergé par la
paroisse de salon-de-provence parti ce
mercredi matin des quartiers nord de
marseille
les deux hommes espèrent convertir de
nombreux français à leur cause
en 1983 il était près 200 mille
personnes à l'arrivée dans les rues de
la capitale
xavier martin quant à eux estiment leur
date d'arrivée à mi juin avec il
l'espère de nombreux compagnons de route